I have an 11-month-old, and one of her
favorite books is The Very Cranky Bear.
But guess what? If I read this book to
her by saying,
"He gnashed his teeth and stomped his
feet and chased them out the door."
She would look at me and think,
"Dad,
where's the emotion?
Where's the animation in your voice? And
why doesn't Bear have a voice and Zebra
have a voice and Lion and Moose?"
She would expect more from me. And to
anyone who's ever read a children's book
to your child or a niece or a nephew or
a younger sibling, you know that a part
of the experience is to use some emotion
in your voice and to tell a great story
because it helps immerse the child in
that story. But for some reason, we
forget this when it comes to giving a
presentation to adults.
And maybe we're nervous about what other
people will think,
but we should not neglect vocal variety.
Vocal variety is one of the most
important aspects of giving a speech and
there can be done many ways in terms of
increasing or decreasing volume or
adjusting the pacing, but in many ways,
vocal variety is actually more important
than the actual words you're saying. One
of the easiest ways to accomplish vocal
variety is to get loud at certain parts
in your presentation. And I'm going to
talk about that in a moment. But first
off, I want to say that the average
volume you have, that base volume
throughout the speech, should be loud
enough for the entire room to easily
hear what you're saying, whether you're
miked or not.
I've often heard from AV people who have
been working at events that I've
happened to speak at talk about trying
to speak to the back of the room, even
if you're miked up.
Essentially, you don't want people to
have to strain and really be listening
carefully to understand what it is
you're saying. It should be a seamless,
easy experience for them to get your
full message. And from there, if
something exciting happens like a bang
in a story,
that's when you can increase the volume.
What this is going to do is it's going
to capture and recapture your audience's
attention.
It almost spikes a little bit of
adrenaline into them and they think,
"Oh." They get immersed in the story,
but also it recaptures that attention
and helps them focus. It essentially
keeps them on their toes. So, increasing
volume is a really powerful way of using
vocal variety. A lesser-known way to
incorporate vocal variety, because many
people know to increase the volume,
but it's to dial it back.
It's to get softer with your voice when
it makes sense to do so.
So, as I mentioned before, it's
important that your base volume when
you're giving a presentation, the
average volume, is loud enough so the
whole room can easily hear you.
But if you're talking about something
emotional
or sad,
it makes a lot of sense to decrease your
volume in those moments.
That is going to draw the audience in.
That is going to recapture their
attention because you're disrupting that
average volume. You're decreasing it for
a moment,
and it immerses the audience. They feel
what you experience, what you felt
because you're matching it with your
voice. So, while many people know to get
louder in a speech,
fewer people know
to dial it back. When it comes to vocal
variety, often people think about the
volume getting louder or getting softer,
but what fewer speakers think about is
the pacing.
But pacing is really cool cuz it can
help take the audience and bring them
into your story.
As an example, let's pretend you're
trying to catch a flight and you're in
the middle of downtown Toronto and
you're trying to find a cab and you're
looking around and finally you spot one
across the street, but you have to dart
in and out of traffic to get there. And
then you open the cab door and you throw
in your backpack and you get in the
backseat and you tell the driver to go
quick because you're running late for
your your flight and the driver is
weaving in and out of traffic going as
fast as he can. And then he pulls up to
the departure gate and you get out with
your backpack and you sprint through the
airport, but it's too late.
You missed your flight.
You're not going to get home on time.
And this is devas- I don't know where
I'm going with this story, but you can
see that the pacing, speeding up when
something is really exciting or there's
a chance that you're going to catch the
plane and the audience is taken with you
on this journey,
>> [sighs]
>> and then slowing down to allow them to
feel the disappointment,
to have empathy for your situation.
That is incredibly important, incredibly
powerful
as a tool that you can utilize as a
speaker. And like I say, more speakers
think about volume, louder, softer, than
they do about pacing, fast and slow. So,
if you can incorporate effective pacing
in your speech,
you're going to be an elite speaker. A
final way you can incorporate vocal
variety is using strategic pauses.
I recently was asked to review a speech
from one of my friends and her speech
was phenomenal. She's going to do an
incredible job when she actually goes to
deliver it.
My only feedback to her was to
incorporate more pausing, especially at
the beginning. You see, she had this
crazy, embarrassing situation happen,
but in the recording that she sent me,
she rushed through this story.
And what took her 15 seconds to tell,
in my mind, this could have been 1
minute if done effectively.
Every sentence was powerful. And what I
suggested to her was to slow down the
pacing and introduce more pauses.
Pauses have two very powerful effects.
First off, if you are saying something
that
is a big idea or something that is hard
to comprehend,
pausing allows the audience to realize,
"Oh, wow." Like the full
power of what was just said, it will
help it sink in. If you were giving a
speech about social media, here's one
way you can introduce pauses.
You could say,
"80% of videos on social media
are viewed without the sound on."
80% of videos on social media are viewed
without the sound on.
These pauses and the repeats allow an
audience to wrap their head around this
surprising or interesting fact. Or if
your company did really well,
you could say, "Our company earned $50
million last year."
This surpassed investors' predictions
by more than 10x.
It's these pauses that allow the message
to sink in. The other place you want to
consider pausing is when you inject
humor. So, if you say something funny,
don't rush to keep talking.
Pause. Make some eye contact with the
audience. And if the laughter starts,
don't cut it off. Allow the laughter to
occur. And sometimes that will build up
to be more laughter.
Pausing can really allow impactful
statements to hit and humor to get the
maximum amount of laughter from
audiences. I hope this video on vocal
variety has been beneficial to you.
As I mentioned, vocal variety is one of
the most important things to consider
when it comes to public speaking. And
there is a speech within the
Toastmasters curriculum that is all
about vocal variety and body language.
And I have a video that will help you
prep for this particular speech. To
anyone who's watching this who is part
of the Toastmasters program, that video
will be popping up on the side. As
always, please consider subscribing to
my channel because it is the best way to
support what I do. Thanks for watching
this one.